This is a multi-device world.
Everyone uses their phone on the go.
>> And they probably sit down with
their laptops when they get home.
>> People probably visit
the same sites on both, but
that doesn't mean that they've
got the same intention.
Yeah.
While you may peruse your favorite
online retailer while you're on the go,
you may not feel comfortable
taking out your wallet and
typing in your payment
information in public.
Or maybe you just don't feel like
dealing with tiny little buttons and
you're in a big rush.
>> So you wait until you get home
to actually make the purchase.
It's perfectly reasonable.
And developers who take advantage of
this pattern stand to convert even
more users.
>> There are a few ways you could help
users start a form on one device and
then finish on another.
For instance,
you could offer them a way to share an
item through social channels or email.
Or there's an even simpler tactic,
save to a shopping cart.
This let's users leave for
now without worrying.
Because they know when
they come back later,
their items will be waiting for them.